hi Chris how are you good Dave I want to
applaud you for helping all the people
out of their debt well thank you sir how
can I help enter there well um I'm not
really in debt but my house paid for my
truck is paid for I live a pretty simple
life but I'm on disability and I want to
do better uh I can't work
I live on a figure of 750 a month
there's that much left there at the end
of the month toonfest I bet I just want
to know what I can do that can maybe
invest a little bit and who to turn to
so that maybe at the later end of time
and by the way I don't have a will and I
heard you talking about that earlier
today and I don't want to put my kids
through a whole heck of a lot of issues
either okay so what color hold on how
old are your kids uh they range from 33
to 21 okay
are you married I I'm widowed okay
all right and what's the nature of your
disability
I got numbers the main one that's
affected me is my COPD and 85 of the
heart Wow
okay how old are you about 58 okay all
right huh well I and you have absolutely
no debt of any kind you wouldn't be
making it on 750 if you did I suppose
well I have I have back I have no credit
it shots you know um you know and I do
have bill collectors that I would really
love to pay oh so you do have debt then
well yes I guess I do okay how much debt
do you have I would say roughly right
around 25,000 and that's on what um
past tool payments child support a
student law okay have you been declared
federally disabled where you're
receiving SSI yes
okay the student loan can be forgiven
and you won't forgive it they have to
it's not all day long is it a federally
insured student loan yes it is yes they
will they just don't know I don't know
how to go about that then it is a
lengthy arduous process but it can be
forgiven and I'll get you some help with
that I'll get one of our counselors in
the area to help walk you walk you
through that so basically what we've got
is your biggest problem I mean you're
doing an amazing job living on $750
that's amazing that you're to be
commended on that and you and so I in
order to do investing we've obviously
got to get your income up and I don't
know how to do that with the limitations
that you have but I am having a good
solid conversation with you for the last
five minutes so I know that you can do
that so maybe there's something that's
that simple that you can do phone sales
or something I don't know
and I don't know what you can do that
doesn't cause disqualification for your
disability we don't want to screw that
up either but boy this is not a the math
of this just is very very tough what you
were saying so what I'd like to have you
do I'll put you on hold and I'll have
Kelly pick up and we're going to set you
with one of our coaches our financial
coaches and I'll pay for it it's no cost
to you okay
and you just sit down with them and see
if they can walk through this with you
and see from a disability standpoint
what you can do legally without causing
a problem for that because I'm not
trying to do that but you do have you do
have just that limitation I mean a
thousand dollars a month would change
your life exactly I mean that's it would
I know what and so in terms of investing
and in going back and clearing up some
of these old debts that can't be
forgiven but and then they can also help
you get that student loan off your
record because a federally insured
student loan when someone is declared
permanently federally disabled is
forgivable but it takes two years worth
a crap because you're dealing with
federal government and you're dealing
with some of the dumbest humans on the
planet in that particular area it's just
crazy
see so we'll help you with a Chris hold
on and I'll have Kelly pick up and we'll
get a financial coach in the area to
help you as a gift from Ramsey solutions
you guys would be so rich so fast and be
able to do so much not only for
yourselves and for your family but for
others
you